[Music]
hi guys I'm Mona Katan co-founder of
head of beauty and que le and today I'm
going to give you guys a little insight
into my quarantine live my quarantine
partner is dr. daddy cool my dad who
also works with us in the company Ryan
Kelly I never get to spend this much
time with my dad so it's actually been
really nice to spend time with him but
also I'm looking forward to being out of
you're not working but no matter what
you're just going to have a vicious
cycle of where your days never have any
structure get a really organized working
station so I have a desk and I also got
a cute table before I was able to lay
out all my samples plan plan everything
another tip I'd like to give you guys is
to make sure you plan to your your next
day and ideally your whole entire week
try to force yourself to stick to your
routine that works for you and try to
like really use this time to master a
new routine like think about you know
are there ways to improve your routine
[Music]
you'll have to do it like the normal way
you cannot [ __ ] with it you know give
honest and sincere appreciation is from
how to win friends and influence people
I love this book by Dale Carnegie I've
read it many times and I like to reread
it often because it's such a great book
and it really really impacted my life
when people tell me thank you it just
makes me want to do more for them so I
think it's just something that we all
feel good when we know people appreciate
what we do for them so give appreciation
as much as you can and make sure it's
sincere but give it as much as you can
actually my entire house is full of
books I love to read and over here my
dad is with one of my looks but he's
still my new hobby that I just started
while in quarantine I actually started
getting singing lessons and you have to
sing I've only had one lesson so far but
when I first got this fridge it was
supposed to go on my near my bedroom and
risk just be only for my perfume but I
ran out of space upstairs so I had a
little drink fridge over here and I have
to end my perfume to keep it cool but I
also have a kombucha it is an acquired
taste to like when I first started
wrecking it was like it tastes so weird
but you get more and more addicted to it
and have some cool flavors all I watch
YouTube channels and I like a lot of
different podcasts so this is impact
Theory
they cover a lot of really awesome
topics
loves Joe Dispenza he is an incredible
doctor that talks about the mind and the
breed is wishful which I absolutely love
I've been using
Yoko to scrub my skin and we've also
launched something masks that first rap
max which is amazing for hydration and
also the chin left which is creeper
lifting and sculpting your chin derma
doctor it's actually really good I love
it this is a I souffle MD&A Madonna's
can come and actually they love this
rose mist so I hope you guys enjoy
today's video and getting to know what
I'm doing behind the scenes in
quarantine I love you guys glamour UK
you guys are amazing
everyone stay safe stay positive stay
loved love you guys so much stay at home
save yourself and your family
[Music]